I'm Sam Lerma I'm the first-time speaker
here at PI data NYC and so my talk today
is graph analytics from the whiteboard
to your tool box so in case anybody
wandered in without reading the abstract
online here's a little bit about what
you can expect over the next forty odd
minutes there's really three big parts
of this so the motivation was I was
studying graph theory on its own for a
long period of time and became
fascinated by how many different
problems you could apply it to and how
great it is to work with it in Python so
I'm going to cover some basic principles
of it if you've had any sort of formal
training in it that'll mostly be a
refresher then I'm going to run through
some basic scenarios you might see and
we're going to talk a little bit about
how you could express it as a graph and
then I'm going to tell you some of the
tools available for working with graphs
and python and show you some code
snippets that we can talk through so
this is a novice level track so I'm
assuming no background on your part
beyond high school math and that you're
familiar with basic Python syntax so the
goal of it is basically for this to be a
jumping-off point for you to go deeper
on your own if you think it's
interesting so don't worry I'm not
expecting you commit to commit these to
memory but basically the reason I wanted
to show these longer definitions is a
lot of the material on graph theory for
its own sake is written specifically for
mathematicians and there's no
universally agreed-upon
terminology for everything so it can
make it particularly confusing if you're
sort of coming in without a strong math
background and you're not used to formal
definitions and proofs and things like
that so whenever I'm teaching on it
here's usually the definition I give
people which is this is a graph I call
it the ball and stick model we've got
ABCD for balls and we have six sticks
between them so right here in the middle
if you ever see to cross each other
without anything think of it as
over-under right they're not interacting
so if you can come up with a way to
explain it in balls and sticks it's
probably a graph so going through a
little bit more of the terminology here
we have two vertices connected by an
edge one thing I want to make clear is
on some people will say node usually
especially if you're working with people
in the software community they're going
to say node so when I'm talking about
the pure stuff I'm going to say vertex
and then I'm going to switch over to
saying node once we get into the code I
might let it slip one way or the other
so just be forewarned so if we have two
connected like this we say they're
adjacent
so adjacent vertices means there's an
edge between them when I'm talking about
the neighborhood of a vertex that means
every vertex that is adjacent to it so
if you can imagine a third one shooting
out right here let's say we labeled at
vertex three the neighborhood of vertex
one would be vertex two and vertex three
so let's look at a little bit more
complicated one with a couple more
things going on just to sort of get you
familiar with some more of the
terminology so up here we've got this
funny edge that goes from A to A that's
called a loop that's loud in some cases
you can also see right here we have
multiple edges between a and B that's
also allowed in certain instances so if
I start talking about the degree of the
vertex that's the number of edges going
into it so the way I think about it if
you were to draw a circle how many lines
would you cross so C has a degree of
three this loop adds two to the degree
so a has a degree of five we can also
start talking about paths that basically
just means if the edges were streets and
you walked from one vertex to another is
that possible so you can get ABCD
without repeating any vertices so we
have a path we can't get from D to G or
anything like that so there's no path
this right here - you might hear me say
cycle that basically just means you can
start follow a path and end up back
where you start so this we'd refer to as
a three cycle I just a couple more
things I want to talk about with this
basically we can think of this as two
sets so this everything in the white is
one graph but they're not connected so
if you hear me talk about disconnected
sets you might hear people say disjoint
sets if they're you know more in the
context of math I'm just going to say
disconnected sets to keep everything as
understandable as possible as you can
see here ABCDE
aren't checked of that so we can split
it into two sets one other important
concept is cut vertex so if we were to
remove a vertex we also take all the
edges jutting out of it with it so going
back to the whole drawing a circle if we
were to remove C we would follow a
circle all the way around it right you
can think of it as following a circular
cut so a cut vertex means if we remove
that vertex we're splitting it in two
more sets
there isn't one here just sort of want
to cover this stuff a little bit quickly
before we start getting into the
examples
so it's also important to talk a little
bit about an adjacency matrix so that's
a nice easy way of representing a simple
graph so if you're looking at the matrix
here we would want to label it left to
right and top to bottom with the nodes
in a specific order
so going alphabetically here ABCD we
would step them off from the top a b c d
and the same way down ABCD so this o is
the 0 is a a a b and so on so with these
lines here represent if there's a zero
there that means it's not adjacent to
the matrix and if there's a one that
means they are adjacent so right here a
a that's a zero if we had a loop there
that would be a one a is adjacent to B
not C but it's adjacent to D so once
again you don't have to remember all
this stuff I just sort of want you to be
aware that these are some of the
concepts before we start applying them
so this is a digraph everything is
exactly the same the only difference is
instead of a stick we've got an arrow
and so we're talking about paths in a
digraph we have to follow the arrows
from one way to another there are
one-way streets so here's a little more
complicated one this is called a
tournament the only important takeaway
point is you can see if we think of
these as wins or losses every vertex is
paired with every other vertex so we can
also talk about in degrees and out
degrees all that means is an indegree
there's an arrow pointing into it and
out degrees an arrow pointing away from
it so that's exactly what it sounds like
this is called a bipartite graph the way
you're going to immediately recognize it
if it's laid out nicely like this is if
you had a pair of scissors and we're to
cut with one motion all the way across
the middle you would disconnect
everything right so a through D aren't
connected to each other and EF G and H
aren't connected to each other so one of
the important concepts I want to talk
about is a matching so that's if we look
at these edges going from one set to the
other can we pair each one from the top
set with the vertex from the bottom set
without adding any new edges so in this
case I drew it so yes we can
and this is a weighted graph so the big
takeaway point with this is we can store
information on edges so if we're talking
about a path these weights add up as you
go from one to the other so if I'm
talking about going from A to B to C
we'd look at the weight of that total
path as 0.5 plus 0.4 so it'd be 0.9 so
that has some applications for
optimization as we're gonna see we can
actually store whatever data we want on
edges in Python and so the last sort of
pure concept I want to talk about is
graph coloring we can color vertices
however we want we can also color edges
although I'm not going to go into too
much detail on that here what you see
here is called a proper coloring so if
you look here that basically means no
two adjacent vertices or the same color
so the reds are not adjacent the greens
are not adjacent and the blues are not
adjacent so if you hear me say proper
coloring that just means we don't have
two vertices next to each other that are
the same color so now that we've kind of
gone through a little bit of the theory
if we're looking at a problem in the
wild what are some signs all right that
a graph might be a good way to think
about it so for me the first question I
ask myself is am i looking at a set of
objects and what I'm trying to find out
is the relationship between them or the
interactions between them that's really
where graph shine we can also think of
one object going through different
transition States so write my background
sort of in the chemical sciences so one
of the big ones we used to do was if
you're looking at a chemical going
through a process every reaction is a
different state so we can start drawing
graphs
sort of on that note when I say
orientation that's basically if we have
different parts of a single object and
we want to see what happens as we move
it what is graph you're going to shine
on that so once again with that rather
famously paraffin waxes have been
studied using graphs basically the
vertices would represent an atom and the
edges would represent a bond that's all
I'm going to say about the chemical side
of it but really one of the valuable
things with this is it can cut across
quite a few different problem spaces so
a lot of these simple techniques can be
applied broadly so let's look at the
first one so you can see here this
already very much looks like a graph
right so if this represented say
Facebook friends call data anything like
that right we have a group of people and
we're trying to find out how they relate
to each other or sort of what we can say
so some of the questions we might want
to ask you're right who's the most
influential how many different people
know each other mutually it's so if we
were to draw it into a graph right this
one's nothing too crazy this looks very
similar but a couple of the things that
if we're looking back at the concepts I
talked about that might stick out so we
have a three cycle here right so we can
see every one of those three vertices is
adjacent to each other so if this did
represent say Facebook friends we would
know that all three of them know each
other we can go and count off the
degrees and if you notice these two red
ones have the highest degree so we know
that there's sort of the most active on
there some of the other concepts we
could put in if this was called data we
could use data directed edges to
represent one person calling the other
or if we were looking at Twitter
followers right we could just decide
which end of the arrows who's following
him so we can start counting off paths
we can start looking at degrees of
separation I'm so particularly like in
law enforcement one of the big things
they do is they look at if you're
counting off all these paths how many
degrees separated our people um so
that's sort of another big big technique
you'd want to use if you're looking at a
social graph so here's another one
actually my first introduction to graph
theory was looking at an e-commerce site
and so you're trying to figure out how
we could model user pass through it so
if you look I have information like this
right we have different pages we know
who viewed what page and when how might
we come up with a graph to represent it
so for me the first thing I thought of
was the pages are obviously going to be
vertices so then the question becomes is
there any information we want to store
on the edge what type of edge is the
most explanatory for this so if we
consider a simplified case this is what
I came up with for the set of web pages
that we were looking at so we can see
here home has nothing but out degrees so
we know that the only time a user
visited that page they came there first
these loops if someone's going from
login to login that probably means
they're refreshing so if you were
looking at something like this and you
saw a ton of loops ticking off that
could be a sign that there's a problem
one of the other interesting things is
comparing in degrees to out degrees so
if you look at product here it has an in
degree of three but an out degree of one
so that could be a sign that the balance
rates particularly high on that page
oops sorry about that how do i zoom out
sorry about that
so if we're looking at product one the
end degree is much greater than the out
degree so our bouncer it's high so if we
were thinking about what information we
might want to store on the edges we
could look at the time between a user
visiting the pages right so if we had a
timestamp for user on whom and a
timestamp for user on login we could
look at the difference and map that as a
weight on the edge so if we were running
an e-commerce site and we're trying to
find the best ways to shuttle users to
payment and eventually success you can
start looking at the weights so even if
they visit more pages if we're pushing
them to that checkout stage faster it
could be a sign that we're making our
site better or worse so that's really
one of the interesting things with this
a couple of the other things I want to
point out here you can see product two
and three we have multiple edges in a
loop so that could show us maybe users
going back and forth maybe there's some
issue so if they were on product three
and it wasn't loading right they could
go to product two and then write back
and then refresh so if we start seeing
weird things like that pop up in the
graph it could be a sign that
something's wrong so a lot of you
probably recognize this type of problem
if we're running a logistics company and
we need to pick something up the train
station deliver it to all these
factories and then return back to say a
trucking garage how can we come up with
a graph to represent that so there's a
bunch of ant ways of attacking the
problem but the way I came up with
represented graphically was the only
real requirement we have is that we need
to go to all the factories in no
particular order so we can't go directly
from Freight in to the end but in theory
any Factory on the list could be the
first or the last one we visit so if we
were going to draw out a graph for this
right we would know that Freight in
can't good record and so those would be
non-adjacent but if we were trying to
consider the space of all possible paths
everything would be adjacent to each
other and so one of the other
interesting questions that comes up here
is if we're trying to optimize for
something how can we bring in those edge
ratings so if we're trying to say
minimize time and transit distance
traveled gas cost whatever we could take
historical data and start putting that
on the edges so the graph that I came up
with was this one so what am i other
favorite things about this is you can
kind of get some cool pictures from
relatively mundane scenarios I didn't
display weights on all the lines I did
try that but it got pretty unreadable
pretty
so up here's the only two weights you're
actually going to see just so you can
see how they would be represented if you
were drawing it visually so every single
vertex here is adjacent to every other
one with the exception that there's no
edge between freight and end so in
theory if we had this and we were trying
to minimize it we would want to find the
shortest path that visits every one of
these vertices starts at freight and
ends at end so actually there's some
pretty cool tools in Python we can use
to do that automatically but if we were
working out on our whiteboard this is
one of the ways we want to approach it
so one other example I want to show you
and to me this is the one that looks the
least immediately obvious that you want
to represent it as a graph so if we're
scheduling a conference and we've
essentially made everybody the promise
if you tell me the top two talks you
want to go to I guarantee you I'm not
gonna schedule them concurrently so you
can make it to both right there's quite
a few ways you could approach this but
one of the ways we can solve it is
graphically and if you notice right if
we had an adjacency matrix we would have
these same labels down the side so it
would be square shaped this is not
square shaped so we know that this is
not in adjacency matrix so if that's
what anybody jumped to that's actually
not the case here but one of the things
we can think of is if we go down this
Bob line right so if a one shows us
they're interested in a zero shows us
they're not
we know that Bob wants to go to E and G
Ashley wants to go to a and C and so on
so if we're trying to come up with a
graph right we're trying to look at the
relationships between people and talks
there's a couple different ways you can
approach it but to me the big thing we
want to look at is making sure you don't
schedule the wrong talks concurrently so
what if we let the talks be the vertices
and the edges represented somebody who
wants to go to both of them right we
would have two connected talks show us
that the same person wants to go to both
so once we have that we can actually go
back to finding a proper coloring right
so if two talks are adjacent on our
graph and then we know that the same
person wants to go to both so we know
that we can't schedule them concurrently
so if we go back and find a proper
coloring we'll know that the minimum
number of colors we need to separate
those vertices based on what's adjacent
is the number of sessions we'd name so
actually this one you would be able to
do it in two if it weren't for these
three that are connected to each other
here so there's a couple different ways
to color
Graf's when you're looking at one at the
moment there's no guaranteed best way
but I'll talk a little bit about some of
the ways we can color them in Python one
word of warning is it can be tricky if
you have a really really convoluted
graph and you're trying to color it so
just keep that in mind when you're
deciding whether or not to use a graph
so the first two graphs libraries in
Python I want to talk about our eye
graph and network X Network X is
probably the most popular and that one's
written specifically for Python and it
does play nice with the PI data stack so
with this one you can kind of pass in
panda data frames and stuff which we'll
talk about but the other big one is
called eye graph so I graph was actually
written for C originally and it's also
available in our package a/c library and
a Python package so if you're a little
more language agnostic and you basically
want to learn one graph package and then
take it to the other languages with you
I'd recommend you start with eye graph
one of the big things is that's a little
trickier to install right with network
access you can just do pip installed
network acts and you're ready to go with
eye graph there's a couple extra steps
particularly if you're on a Windows
machine that said it is a little bit
more efficient the network acts if
you're starting to work with a really
really big graphs or look at complicated
algorithms one other library I want to
bring up is called graph tool so this is
essentially Python bindings for the C++
boost graph library there's quite a bit
of testing data going between eye graph
and graph tool as to which one's faster
my rule of thumb is graph tool is going
to be a little bit faster at least
everything I've used it for that said it
is the hardest of the three to get set
up and you sort of need to write your
code a little bit differently because if
you come in and you start just calling
the built-in functions you might end up
not offloading as much work to graph
tools you want and you really won't get
that C++ speed advantage so what I'm
going to focus on for these examples is
actually Network tax just because this
is PI data not C data and not our data
but I want you to know these other two
out there so if you're an environment
where little performance boosts are
important you might not want to start
with Network tax so there's a couple
different ways we can share graphs once
we've created them this graph ml versus
GML sort of solved the same problem just
ones ascii-based
and one is xml based it's really up to
you which one you want to use based on
your preference
like I said with Network action actually
pass in adjacency matrices using numpy
or using pandas so that is one nice
thing realistically the other ones will
create a graph for a minute Jason C
matrix but you will have to make sure
you convert it or you're going to get an
error so if not the end of the world
it's just one more thing you have to
worry about if you sort of go too far
off the ranch outside the the Python
libraries so here's how we would create
a graph in network X so the pretty latex
drawings are gone these are just the
matplotlib basic ones but essentially
right we didn't for Network X the
matplotlib is for python all three of
the libraries I talked about have a
graph class so when you initiate them
you're always going to call the library
abbreviation graph and then we can start
assigning information to that class as
we want to construct the graph so here
you can see we're gonna pass in a
container of vertices I just made a list
and then you know added five to them
that's another one of the really
powerful things here is we can once
we've decided what we want to store as a
node we could run whatever data
operations we want pump them into a list
and then started setting up our graph
that way this command here add edges
from we passed it was called an e bunch
and network X parlance that's edge bunch
so that's essentially a container of
edges here I passed at a list of tuples
that's usually the way I do it but
they're pretty loose with what types of
containers you can pass them so you can
get a little bit creative with that just
be careful as far as plotting we need a
position argument here
so spring layout is the one that most
people use by default with network acts
that's sort of some rules as to how to
place them there are other ones you can
use them so I have a circular layout I'm
going to show you a little bit later on
but there's quite a few different ways
you can arrange it realistically it only
matters for visualization and network X
does have a lot of other visualization
libraries you can work with so that's
really the only time that's going to be
important for displaying we also have
this draw syntax where we tell it to
draw everything individually so if you
forget to call draw you're going to get
a weird-looking graph so for instance
right if I cut this Network Facts labels
line out and ran it these nodes over
here wouldn't be labeled right so three
four to one five those would just show
up like
it really won't affect your operation
too much but if you're trying to sanity
check parts of it you can end up with
weird results part way through so here's
how we would store weight on the edges
if you notice the last one the nodes
were all ants here the strings any
hashable object can be an ED so you have
some freedom with what you want to store
as a node and the other thing I want you
to look at is here this is a dictionary
so we can store whatever data we want on
these edges we can start more than one
piece we can have weight length width
whatever we want so if we're building
out a graph and we want to start looking
at the looking at it edgewise we need to
go through those dictionaries so you can
see here the way I added it was I just
put an extra argument at the end it
automatically converted that weight to a
string when it showed it to me but
they're now stored as dictionaries on
the edges so in theory I could just
store whatever I wanted down there so
you spring that again and back here
we're drawing everything the only real
difference is I had to add another
dry-aged labels line so one of the other
nice things with the draw is this can
get cluttered so if I had length which I
originally did when I was drawing this
it didn't space the nodes properly so
you had all kinds of dictionaries and
stuff running over it can be kind of a
mess and so if you're somebody who
doesn't want to spend a bunch of time
visualizing it bear that in mind
so I usually recommend you know drawing
a small one on your own and then doing a
couple sanity checks as you go down the
line
so say we've already built this big
convoluted graph there are a couple
different functions that network
exercise built-in trust analyze it so if
we call nodes it's just going to give us
a list of all the nodes we're allowed to
mix data types they're some of the notes
can be strings some of them could be
images some of them could be integers so
that's just gonna spit back a list
containing all the nodes this shortest
path we pass it G which is the graph
object right that we created a start
node at a target so it's going to go
through it's going to run a Dijkstra's
shortest path is the implementation in
network X and it's basically just going
to find the shortest one one another
word of warning here is if you have two
equally short paths if you just pass it
the shortest path function it's going to
only give you one of them so if it's
important to find all the paths there
are a couple different ways you can do
it this might not be the one and if we
call G dot degree that's going to count
the degrees on every node
and then give us back a dictionary so
here it's a little bit confusing looking
just cuz we have incidents but
realistically if we mix them the key is
going to be the note identifier and then
the value is just going to be an int
representing the number of degrees so
you've ever the color and glass earlier
right so let's think about how we would
color it a little bit with Network X so
if you were looking at scheduling or any
sort of concurrency placement this is
the way you'd want to do it so I didn't
show you creating the graph but this is
an X dot greedy color is going to use a
greedy algorithm to color it another
little caveat here is if you're working
with more complicated graphs greedy
coloring will not necessarily always
give you the minimum in this case it did
just because it was simple but their
order in which nodes are considered is
important so if you go under the network
X documentation there's a couple
different strategies you can use to
order them I figured that was a little
bit outside the scope of this talk but I
want everyone to be aware of it before
you start going crazy this was just me
being lazy with the way to count up the
number different colors but you can see
here it did actually the same coloring
we did where F is the odd one out and so
it had three different colors so if we
were to so if we were to run this
basically out in the real world that's
that's one of the ways we could do it so
here's a digraph this is really where
edges become important so it's going to
look out degree in degree right so one
two is not two one when we're passing an
edge to poles one of the other nice
things is we can call right we can set
it up and just pass a list of edges and
it will create nodes as it sees fit I've
gotten weird results with this before
you know if maybe I pass it edges that
refer to five nodes it'll just add an
extra one so be a little bit careful
when you do that if you notice here we
didn't call a next graph I called nxi
graph there are a couple different types
of graphs that we can use with network
acts there's multi graph which will
allow multiple edges digraph is
directional there are a couple other
ways you can get creative and sort of
mix directed and undirected edges
although I wouldn't recommend it but you
can see the graph creation process is
almost identical the only thing I did
was to change a node size and the font
so we could see those arrow heads a
little bit
one of the other interesting ones so as
I mentioned if we start looking for
paths through the graph and it has to
respect these arrowheads if you notice
here number 5 only has in degrees so we
can get to 5 but we can't get out once
we're there so if I call this has path
function that's going to give us a
billion so if you are looking at you
know website data you could call this
house path and see if a user went from
one page to the other at any point and
this shortest path basically does the
same thing it's going to give you a list
referring to the nodes that you can take
for the shortest path through those are
a couple of the digraph functions and
blast ones so I talked about a matching
I didn't have an example it was a little
bit concerned about time but if we have
one of these bipartite graphs you can
see there's the snip you would make in
one motion this will find the biggest
possible matching so it's just going to
return us set a tuples and it looks like
I'm a little bit short on time but a
couple of other resources I wanted to
point out in case anybody does decide
they want to go deeper tomorrow actually
somebody's leading a network X tutorial
so it's kind of a nice little surprise
it's right here in this room I think at
10 a.m. so if you do want to go hands-on
or you thought I sort of moved through
it too fast it'll be a nice slower one
so I'd strongly encourage anyone who's
interested to check that out craft biz
was what I used to create the black and
white graphs at the beginning you can
run that in Python but if you just want
to practice drawing them there's
actually an in-browser graph is you can
use just web graph viscom there is a
free graph theory textbook as well it's
going to have a little bit of
combinatorics in it but if you're more
interested in the math that one's
license in the Creative Commons you can
google for it and you'll find it online
as a nice little PDF graph theory is an
area that still has a lot of great work
that needs to be done and unlike a lot
of other math areas there are open
problems that undergrads are capable of
solving and undergrads have solved so if
you're a little more interested in the
academic route and getting published
that's actually a great site to go to
open problem garden there's a graph
theory category and you can actually
output your graphs as checks packages so
if you're looking to write in latex or
anything like that for publishing not
all three of these graph packages I
talked about will let you produce tick
or ticks graphs so you can embed them
directly into your papers graph
databases or another interesting field
right it's a little bit outside the
scope of this conference
but if you're interested the biggest
vendor neo4j will trade you in a reilly
book for some personal data about
yourself so if you really want to know
you can go give them your email and
where you work and stuff and they'll
send you a free one there's also a
pretty interesting workshop I found one
of the areas I didn't talk about just
because it's above my pay grade is
language processing but there's some
pretty exciting work going on right now
and using graphs to analyze how language
is structured and then lastly if you're
working in a very specific problem area
and you're curious about some of the
other graphs people have come up with
that cite ResearchGate net it's like a
social networking site for scientists
everybody wants someone to read their
papers so there's a lot of open access
ones and if it's closed you can ask them
nicely and they'll usually send you a
copy that's all I got I don't know how
much time we have left for questions
before the next person is to come in we
have time for questions
[Applause]
hey thanks I found this really like
informative I just had a quick question
so as far as like modeling concerns um
with Django it's actually like kind of
discouraging because it's you know
creates a database and like they say
like you don't want to alter the
database it's like it induces a lot of
anxiety like iterating over the design
to come up with some of those models was
that an iterative process or do you try
to draw it out perfectly the first time
so for these graph models yeah
originally it was iterative after you've
done it a few times you sort of get an
instinct and you can start seeing graphs
everywhere you look so one of the things
I recommend if that's what you want to
improve on is go to research gate and
look at how people have come up with
other graphs or if you just Google you
know graph theory applications for
database design or for image recognition
there's tons of people who want you to
look at the graphs they've come up with
so it's a really nice sort of open area
of math so there's there's a lot of cool
work you can find out that's like
changing it wouldn't affect like your
database rating there so like a in a
graph database for changing the graphic
or is that the question
well like just like changing the chart
wouldn't affect like just like if you're
modeling the network acts yeah depending
on what you change the nice thing is of
the packages I I mentioned network axe
handles dynamic graphs the best so if
you're gonna change it sort of in
process I'd recommend start with a small
one
Network X and then if performance is a
concern maybe move out to the other ones
but for the most part changing stuff
isn't terribly difficult very good thank
you so much thanks that's really
interesting do you have this sort of
maybe outside of the Python sort of
scope but you have any experience with
like graph like query languages or like
ways to like query graph databases so
the one I've used the most as far as
graph databases is neo4j they have their
own curry language called cipher that
I've spent quite a bit of time fighting
with okay it's actually kind of
interesting they have like a little
arrow syntax you can follow the edges
through that's where I'd recommend
starting just because there's the most
information about it but ciphers you'll
know and I've used although there's a
bunch of other ones anybody else for any
more questions maybe the last great talk
it just seemed like there's an awful lot
of intuition required in choosing you
know what's gonna be a node what's gonna
be an edge if if you were talking to
someone like myself in a situation where
maybe I know what my nodes are but I've
got two or three hundred different
flavors and options for edges yeah any
any advice there yeah so that's there's
no universal rule that I know if I can
give you one of the things I recommend
is if you're working within a very
specific space look at what other people
have done so a lot of these graphs
follow similar patterns right so for me
I was working in logistics most recently
so I pulled research gate papers on
other stuff people have done in the
logistics area I was able to get some
insight usually if you're thinking about
that object relationship model the
relationship in question is what you'd
want to use as an edge so you know
beyond that you kinda have to play with
it but if you do it a few times you'll
quickly see what's reasonable and what
isn't but as you get down to more
specific areas there's rules of thumb
yeah sorry I kind of murdered through it
because we had IT trouble at the
beginning so if there are any other
questions I'll be lurking around feel
free to come grab me I love talking
about this stuff so I'd be happy to
answer anything on the fly